call to order a meeting of the children
and family law Committee of the House of
Representatives for Tuesday January 30th
before we have our first bill hearing uh
a few items that were raised uh just now
at the chairs and vice chairs meeting
with the
speaker they really really really want
the committee reports coming in a timely
manner or we will be doing all nighters
and having been in that great uh
marathon before we shut down for covid
when we stopped at 353
a.m you don't want to do this that means
when we exec a
bill the committee report needs to be
written and given to whom
me I corrected for spelling grammar and
so on
um I can actually kick it back to you
and say I don't like it I've never done
that I don't see that I would need to
but I can do that once I do that I hand
it to the clerk or one of the clerks who
then does what he or she needs to and it
goes to a committee assistant this
should be the same day he we exact they
really are emphasizing
this next item on a bill if um there's
an amendment coming an amendment can be
drafted by anybody well anybody in the
house but it can only be presented in an
exact session by one of us so if you
know we've heard a bill and somebody
says well I think that would be improved
if we do this I'm going to get an
amendment that's all well and good but
one of us has to be the one to introduce
it from Anne Fitzgerald who is uh the
boss on the fourth floor She says after
we're done please pick up after
yourselves paper water cups water
bottles notice she didn't say coffee
cups because we don't have coffee here
and I know what muddy water looks like
and that isn't muddy water that's coffee
okay also check your mailbox in the
committee room last time we met only
five of us could get here and so we uh
decided all that nice paper shouldn't go
to waste and uh we put some of the items
we didn't exec anything we didn't have a
quorum so we put paper from the hearings
of last time in your mailbox in
whichever committee room is ours your na
names should be on those little
draws uh what
else
um when
you offer an amendment to
OS they'll let you know when it's done
they do not automatically send it back
over you have to call them up and say
wonderful job please send it to
committee
Services it doesn't happen
automatically
also I can't call them up and say
representative so and so has a wonderful
amendment I just heard about it would
you send me a copy their answer is
no not yet but you can send it if it's
your Amendment you can send it to
anybody you want but if you send it to
the entire committee please folks don't
comment on it and then hit send to all
that's the 91 a violation you can take
the amendment and I like to see
amendments ahead of time to be better
prepared for an exec session you can
send it to everybody but then we can
only discuss it in twos and threes or in
a party caucus espcially called
caucus a little bit about
February um I'm going to skip a few
weeks and go with the 15th that's a
thirs Thursday we start at 1 p.m. the
governor's State of the State address uh
and then after that we have a voting
session we may want a committee meeting
that
morning and you've already been you know
asked to hold all Thursdays in February
so we may meet in the morning because
that way we may not have to have an
other day when you wouldn't normally
have been here so hold the entire
15th on the 22nd we will probably go
late this is one of those rare
occurrences where there are five
Thursdays in February it's a leap year
and that's school vacation so we won't
be meeting any any little procedural
questions you may have from
that okay thank
you I open the hearing on House Bill
1392 relative to consideration of the
opinion of the child in determining
parenting time F flown in at Great
expense is our very own representative
Gibbons
welcome thank you Mr chairman um so I'm
the only sponsor on this uh bill just
because I did most of this work during
the summer um and I did a lot of
research
about uh how to get the child heard in
court uh the child has a right to be
heard um and the problem is though that
bringing a child into court to give
their their own testimony can be
traumatic to the child um and this comes
from scientific
research
uh about about um what I was looking up
with the the child giving uh
their opinion about kind of anything
going on with their family
so um so New Hampshire law currently
states that if the child is of
sufficient maturity then they can give
their opinion but how does one determine
if the child is of sufficient maturity
well the judge has to make that
determination and so then it turns out
that the judges generally AR aren't
making those determinations because to
bring them in to the court to make that
determination is potentially traumatic
if they find that the child is not
mature enough to give their opinion so
they caused trauma without hearing the
child's opinion and
so they just kind of the the courts
generally just stay away from from that
alog together so I was like well how do
we solve this
so basically I wanted to get an outside
opinion of the child to come to the
court to to heal that amends that that
that break there um so if the child has
a therapist someone that knows the child
well um at a at a pretty deep level uh
then they can offer and just a oneliner
you know that this child is mature
enough to give their opinion in court
like simple and I thought that that was
I thought that that was great and and I
got some good feedback that well we
don't want to put the child into a
situation where they're
testifying against the parents and it's
like well that's really true so I agree
with that um so I was given some
feedback that maybe the child should
uh give their opinion to the judge in
Chambers um so that the parents can't
hear so that the child is not testifying
against one parent or the other I
thought that was a great idea so I so I
asked OSS to make an
amendment and and they they put it
together for me um but then uh our good
chairman uh Mark Peterson uh got me in
touch with uh her first name is Aaron
she is a
lawyer who is like an in between uh
between the judges and the legislature
and she and I had a phone call that this
is addressing an issue that they see
frequently in the courts and it's an
important issue to address however um if
the child gives their opinion to the
judge in Chambers then it creates an
appet issue because uh the party the the
divorcing parents or or the single
parents
um then don't have access to all the
testimony and that's an impellent
issue so at this time I am waiting for
she is going Aaron is going to contact
the judges to get their opinions to find
out what is the best way to address this
issue she's going to circle back with me
and I'm going to ask OS to write another
amendment um and then I will submit that
to this committee um so I'm happy to
take your
questions also just as a as a reminder I
am on board with the parents having
equal parenting time so when I'm when
I'm wanting the child to be able to
State their opinion because they have
the right to be
heard I'm not asking for the child to
pick one parent or the other um I'm I'm
of the mindset that the child wants to
spend equal time with both parents and
this might be a situation where the
child wants to spend
Friday with the
dad because their friend next door is
having a sleepover party something like
that you know something really benign um
maybe the the child wants to spend
Tuesdays with parent a and Thursdays
with parent B you know something like
that um it it's very frequently that
they'll do every other weekend so we
don't really need to parse that out um
but their opinion about what the 50%
looks like is is kind of what I'm
after
to TI
Panic thank you chairman uh for letting
me ask this question and thank you uh
for letting me ask this question is this
already in place with the guiding at
lams so that's in very interesting that
you brought that up um that came up in
my conversation with Aaron
and and I asked about that you know who
and she she mentioned that Guardian at
lims tend to be the in between however
they are not funded by the state and so
they are not accessible to people that
can't pay for them so there's a
significant number of families that
don't have Financial access to have a
guardian at lium and that's where this
becomes an
issue thank anyone else representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my call um should the um
should it be determined that a therapist
is necessary and um there's to determine
whether the child is of a m level of
maturity to um testify um if the child
does not has not had a Therapist
assigned and the parents are do not do
not have find
Financial Resources to afford a
therapist um how would that situation be
handled according to your bill yes thank
you for that question um that was in the
OS amendment that I'm not presenting
right now um and it's the the answer is
that a school therapist could could also
uh do that assessment um and that might
end up in my second amendment um cuz my
second amendment will be depend on what
the on what feedback I get about from
the judges on So if they still want an
outside source of assessment um then
I'll keep the school counselor part in
there um so yes it is the the issue is
addressed I'm just not presenting it
right now because we're going to be
doing a second amendment so there's no
need to give the First
Amendment representative sidel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um in your bill it
spec it doesn't specify a type of
therapist there's like 18 different
types of therapists is it any type or
specific um I wasn't specific about it
um the goal was just to have a
professional who knows the child well to
because all they're doing is they're not
doing like a like a deep psychological
assessment they're just saying if the
child is mature enough to be able to
give their opinion in court court so
that going to court actually provides a
benefit and not any type of negative for
the child
so representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson thank
you for your testimony um if you could
just clarify for me it already says if
it finds clear and convincing evidence
and it also says if there are other
factors so I'm wondering why the
therapist reports are input from these
other professionals wouldn't be already
submitted as part of the evidence or as
another
Factor where what line are you looking
at I'm looking at line
14 and let say it says it up on the top
too right because it says if they're of
sufficient maturity but the issue is how
to determine if they're of sufficient
maturity and the issue at hand was
that um
it given given no data then the judge
would have to make that assessment and
they generally weren't doing that
because it would bring trauma to the
child to bring them in court especially
if it's determined that they're that
they're not of sufficient
maturity so they wanted like not
traumatize the child followup thank you
chairman Pearson so I'm still a little
confused because then what is the when
they're determining if the child is of
sufficient matur and they have to have
clear and convincing evidence what is
that evidence that they're using if
they're not using reports from the
school or input from it would generally
just be the judge's
assessment of the
child but but if they if we can get an
outside report then we take that burden
off of the
judges to have to do that
assessment um the chair um does that
does that me did I answer your question
representative Paul thank you you
chairman par I'm still a little bit I I
I understand what you're saying I
totally I get that that the judge talks
to the child but he must have other
evidence that's been presented in order
for him to um for him to even come to an
opinion or these or it says or other
factors
um the court shall also give due
consideration to other Factor so I'm
just wondering why um written testimony
or someone else coming in to testify
wouldn't or a therapist wouldn't be
qualified as other factors well because
like the child's age is usually a factor
like if they're you know 12 years old
and greater for example then they're
generally considered mature enough um to
give their opinion but when they're in
that in between stage where they're not
a young child clearly can't give their
opinion to court but it's that in
between stage that pre-teenage and and a
little bit younger where where their
maturity might be in
question um so I think I think by you're
right it is vague and that's kind of my
point of why I wanted to clarify it is
it your testimony that your conversation
so far with people in Family Court are
is that um they
don't know how to do this or they're not
doing this which seems everything in law
notwithstanding
they need help correct yes and my
followup is that you went to the source
and said judges how may we help you yes
exactly and that's where we're that's
where we're at a at a standstill right
now because I'm waiting to get that
feedback so so we've identified an issue
that does exist um where the the law is
vague and needs Clarity and because the
judges don't want to cause trauma to the
child
without any type of benefit they
generally don't bring the children in
but then that but the child has a right
to be heard so so we're trying to figure
out a third way that'll work and you you
brought the judges in on it exactly okay
yes and and guardian at lims are
generally the method that that is used
but is not accessible to some families
and your Amendment will deal with issues
of bringing in a school coun or perhaps
you're trying to give several options so
that the judge may be uh more
comfortable in rendering his or her
opinion about the maturity is that that
way you're going with this exactly okay
because if the if it's determined that
the child is mature enough to give their
opinion about the situation because it's
their it's their life you know if they
want to spend time with you know the
neighbor at Dad's house because they're
having a birthday party because they
have a pool in the summer you know then
they can give that opinion and and the
child can spend certain days over with
Dad you know it's it's about how what
the 50% looks like sure not because I
don't think that the child should be in
a position where they determine
parenting time um we have enough we have
enough difficulty with that as it is
anyway so we don't want to bring the
child into that it's just what the 50%
looks like does it look like this and
then some weeks like that you know um
okay any other
questions uh yes representative long had
been next y thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um so this
assessment is this a written assessment
it in my mindset yes um but I'm still
waiting for feedback from the judges
okay and uh follow up if I may follow up
um could I go to my first hearing and
let the judge J know that I hired a
therapist for the majority of my minor
sure uh to give an assessment so that
appointment's not till a couple months
yeah sure okay yeah because we know that
these you know divorces and and whatnot
with with families takes a long time so
a few months is nothing in the grand
scheme of things okay uh one more
followup one more followup yeah the with
respect to the
um
uh with respect to the
um termination of parental rights for
example I want my I want my son to play
football his mother does it ask the
child my son's mature wants to play
football so he could say I'm I want to
be with my dad Monday through Friday for
football
practice so that that would be one of
the determinations that the judge could
make yeah if the child says that sure
okay great thank you my whole point is
that you know it's the child's life and
so if the judge asks if it's if it's a
situation where Monday through Friday
they want to be with the dad then I
would expect the that the judge knowing
that there should be 50/50 ask the child
well how do you want to spend what do
you want the your time with your mom to
look like and then get the child's
opinion on that
so the judge doesn't have to the judge
does not have to order according to the
child's opinion but I want the CH judge
to hear the child's opinion because the
child probably has reasons like like you
were saying you know they're on the
football team so they want to be at
Dad's house or whatever um maybe it's a
few hours with Dad and a few hours with
Mom each day um but just get the child's
opinion it's their life
representative
Raymond uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh my
question is a little bit different and
in that do we know if there are
therapists that do this and if it would
be covered by medical insurance because
I'm I'm thinking that the majority of
parents don't have you know $250 an hour
or more right to spend on a therapist to
get to know their child to write a
report if like if this is a service that
therapists provide um I did ask one
therapist and they said that they
could so but I can't speak for all
therapists um just based on what one
said to me but I would expect that they
would be able to write just a oneline
statement
yeah and and like the amendment that I
have that I have not presented says that
a school counselor could if the family
doesn't have a therapist so there
doesn't have to be outof pocket
costs representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and for presenting your bill
today I'm wondering about maybe
unintended consequences in this on one
hand we're saying that we want the child
to um be able to have a say but we're
also saying well but they can't say like
50/50 or whatever and that's your that's
what you're saying right so you want
them to have a partial say in their life
well so I'm under the assumption because
we we passed HB
185 um and we have other bills that are
in the works for this year that about
equal parenting time so if the
underlying assumption is equal parenting
time then we're not determining
parenting time we're just determining
what the 50% looks like if it means a
couple hours every day because they want
to go to football practice and then they
want to have sleepover with Mom you know
then that's what they want you know but
the judge doesn't have to order
according to the child's opinion if the
if the judge
disagrees um follow follow up go ahead
all right so the next part I have is so
even the most mature child can uh
especially when parents have not gotten
long and they can't come to an agreement
can um turn the situation because that's
their survival into a a bidding match as
far as okay I'm going to I'm mad at my
mom today and I'm going to teach her
this L this um you know I'm going to say
I don't want to be with her on these
days because I'm going to show her or
maybe it's Dad they want to do that too
what is this not adding more
complications to the court system by
letting a child who no matter how mature
does not have the developmental skills
to reason through certain things um this
much power or if they're not listened to
this much disappointment like is this
not just a huge complicating thing well
and that's that's part of why I want was
originally thinking that the child
should should testify in Chambers but
then I found out that that's an
appellate issue so we're trying to
figure out how to work that out so
that's where the experts are going to
come in and they're going to weigh in on
it um
and I did suggest to eron that maybe we
can just put in a line saying that the
child's testimony does not create an
appet issue
um so because the the issue was that if
the parents don't have access to all the
testimony then that's cause for for
appealing but if we just simply say
that that the child's testimony in
Chambers isn't
isn't due cause for for appealing then
that might be our solution so I'm I'm
waiting to hear back on
that would has it been so far your
conclusion from speaking with people in
family court that judges who have been
in family court for several months or
longer can kind of figure out when one
parent is playing off against the other
or the child is trying to manipulate
that that this isn't their first rodeo
on this hypothetical sure I would assume
that yes I think that would be safe to
assume um yeah I I will come back to
this committee with with the expert
opinions once I have them thank you so
much anything further I have no pink
cards meaning no one has signed up to
testify on this bill and if you wish to
testify on the other two bills we have
this morning uh need to fill out pink
cards but thank you very much with that
we conclude the hearing on this bill and
because there is an amendment coming we
are not exing and we will be in uh
standown for about 3 or 4
minutes
representative the
building
yeah I have any trouble getting in this
morning the back
that's
open the hearing now on House Bill 1340
relative to exclusion of incarceration
as voluntary unemployment for the
purposes of calculating child support
and our own representative David
Bickford is the prime
sponsor thank you Mr
chairman I'm here today to introduce HB
1340 which is relative to exclusion of
incarceration as voluntary unemployment
for purposes of calculating child
support and uh I got into this because
this book this book was put out the
review
of uh New Hampshire child support
guidelines back December of the last day
of 2022 and I started looking at it in
January and uh they made a number of
suggestions or recommendations in it um
of which I seized upon a few and decided
we'll clean some of the stuff up this is
one of them on page 158 of this book
there's a
recommendation uh to do what we have in
front of us and that is to add
to uh the
RSA 458 C to Roman 4A provided that no
case shall in uh incarceration be
considered voluntary
unemployment and the reason that is is
because the Supreme
Court um came down and it's on the
second page of what I passed you out
that's the Supreme Court decision in
and most of the information on it is of
course on these decisions is on the back
page or the next to last page
um and it was uh it was judge lyen that
sits right here that wrote wrote this on
the other day so
um I I don't want to read it just a
bunch of stuff to you here let me see if
I can shrink this up
um
um no not
that I thought I was
organized on the front page this where I
should have start is this is about
codifying New Hampshire case law that
does not treat incarceration as
voluntary unemployment the New Hampshire
practices to consider the actual
circumstances of a parent when income
imput ation is authorized this would
bring New Hampshire in compliance with
the
2016 added Federal requirements so
that's the second reason so there's a
case law that says don't do it and
there's also the 2016 Federal
requirements that says don't do it to uh
to un to unambiguously comply with the
requirement to not treat incarceration
as voluntary employment there should be
no exception in the provision
based on the reason for
incarceration now this doesn't mean that
another source of income for this person
that's incarcerated can't be tapped as I
understand but you can't say well you
still got to pay your child support just
the same as if when you weren't um
incarcerated so
uh I'll take questions that's all I have
to say right now oh J okay yeah
um okay I saw you is good from that
side I saw first hand up was Nelson and
then I'm going down the road
representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking my um my question so
um
I um trying to work through this I'm not
trying to give you a hard time when I
ask you that question I just want to
preface this but um what uh so what you
are saying is that child support can
be um can be revised yeah um and so that
the period of time that the person is
incarcerated there will be no
aages um well you I believe I believe
this is a change um that you'll drop
down to the minimum amount because what
the decision is it's not voluntary uh
you didn't voluntarily go to
prison okay it used to be a case called
nden versus nden that uh the courts were
relying on and people that were
incarcerated would continue to have
their child support AC crew and of
course when they get out now they go
back because they hadn't they so far
behind they couldn't pay
it okay go ahead um okay I'm I'm getting
I'm getting this the wheels are turning
thank you but um is is it um an unfair
burden for the parent who has custody of
the children to have that burden without
being able to count on um
aages during the time of incarceration
it just can you help me work through
that a little bit well your child
support is generally uh say wage
assignment yeah and they'll they'll take
that out and like in this case the
fellow was uh on job that um and he was
arrested on lost his job because he was
arrested prosecuted went to jail or
prison I'm not sure which and uh so we
couldn't pay and I think there's another
um Supreme Court this I think the US
Supreme Court I thought but you know the
people behind me can probably answer
that better than I can okay um you asked
about fairness I I don't know if I can
answer that but yeah as far as income is
concerned they're not making income so
therefore you can't garnish income they
don't have I think that's where it comes
from but like I said when Justice Lyn is
taking this room tomorrow well we can
ask him because he wrote the
decision representative
Greg I guess
I'm so I I understand the idea that they
didn't they weren't didn't voluntarily
become incarcerated but they did did
they not voluntarily choose the action
that led them to be
incarcerated I I remember that back in
2004 when I was on the child support
commission that was the answer well they
shouldn't have done the crime then well
yeah I just I mean it's um there are
some sorry followup yes thank you uh
there are some spouses that will go to
pretty um big lengths to not pay child
support just out of a punishment or
whatever so I guess in this case what
protections are we giving to or holding
for the parent that has to then pay
everything for the child well actually
we're not doing anything more than just
writing it into the statutes which is
the the law books over there we're going
to have it in the law book so people can
see it it's actually the law of the land
now it's it's it's the law of New
Hampshire now because the New Hampshire
Supreme Court already ruled on it so
that's all we're doing here is codifying
okay thank you decisions already made
could we have chapter and verse where it
is
codified yeah well yeah I did read that
too you want it again I yeah yeah it's
in the bill it's in the first too huh
thank you yeah okay right the first
sentence it's amazing what you can see
just by
looking
yeah well but the real the real experts
on child sports are behind me I'm going
to withdraw that um
what I can see because RSA 458 C2 Roman
4 small
a is amended by this bill yeah so it is
not the law of the state presently well
it's case law of the state it's only
case law only I beg you pardon uh that
is uh I believe third in the
hierarchy um of importance it's not
unimportant but there are more important
things which is why you're seeking to
get it into statutory law yes so it it
is case law you're seeking to get it
into statute exactly because of among
other reasons the study and the fact
that there was a Supreme Court decision
in the state yes and do you have
reference to that louder decision and I
have that in the paper I passed out to
you it's on the second second page is is
the the decision itself okay uh we will
stop this brain cramp and now call on
representative side Al sorry about that
so thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um because they would
not be if they're if they're
involuntarily incarcerated and would not
have to pay child support or pay the
minimum is there do you find that that
there would be any room in your bill to
amend it to make the payments that
they're not no longer making retroactive
to the
obligate um I have not done that of
course as you can say um I'm just trying
to get it into the statute books because
of the recommendation that came from the
um this the the people that studied the
child support system um we paid
$116,000 um to have this report and
every four years we have another one the
last one was about $140 I believe, and
they made a recommendation says Hey
because of the Supreme Court decision
you should and the 2016
Federal uh decisions and I should call
decision the uh uh the government
Congress uh changed some laws and said
we need to do this so it's just a matter
of getting it out there so it's in the
open I uh to digress a little bit I I
did a bill here in judiciary and it was
because the New Hampshire Municipal
Association was going around and telling
the towns in the school district that uh
they couldn't accept electronic uh uh
write to no requests and send out
electronic information and so that was
really bogging things down and so I
filed the bill to make it the way we've
been doing it and lo behold the lady
called me up and says you know what
judge Glenn already signed a decision on
that it's called the green decision and
uh so everybody thought it was still a
really good idea to get these things
into the statute books instead of
because people don't I think they call
it Shepherd eyes um and go back and see
what case law has decided on these
things so if you already got a statute
that talks about it you might as well
put it in there so it's in one place
that's all we're really doing here yeah
representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman uh there
is a separate bill in the house this
year that I believe um that wants to
raise the minimum wage of uh imprisoned
people people to the state minimum wage
um so I'm wondering how that would
work uh I I I have a lot of questions
about that bill in general uh but I'm
wondering how that would
work in conjunction with this bill well
I would think if it got a high enough I
mean if they're does that mean they're
employed they have sources they still
have sources like I said it doesn't it
doesn't excuse if you have other sources
of income MH but you can't say that
they're voluntary that's all the bill
and this decision does you can't claim
that person voluntarily unemployed
because there are people that have done
that you know say I don't have to pay
jobs I'm not working I quit and so right
so then the government came back and
says well we know how to handle that but
it got too far out of hand and that's
like I said uh that's when this decision
came along sure yeah I understand that
I'm just wondering how those two would
work because if in other words if
they're if they're not voluntarily
unemployed and then they're making money
in the prison system then shouldn't that
come together and because if they were
if they're making the state minimum wage
I'm not sure how many hours they're
expected to work and I'm not sure if
they can choose their hours there's a
lot that I don't know about the what
what how it works but if they're working
40 hours a week at State minimum wage as
a as an imprisoned person then I would
think that they would ow ch child
support my guess is they would still be
expected to pay child support if they
got money they can pay child support
right that's just that's my guess again
there's people behind me that's much
that's just much more knowledge than
that than I have right and and we we
still need to know if that bill is even
going to pass but it's just in the works
this current year legislative year so I
would just wonder how they would work
together yeah I guess I should say I
don't
know I S hand this way did I see a hand
this way there was a hand this way
representative ball thank you chairman
um and thank you for being here and
thank you for presenting this bill um my
question and excuse me if I I have to
ask the question because I'm a little
bit confused for a family will this make
a difference of the eligibility for
social support if as the difference
between a parent just not paying so he's
weigh in a rears versus the parent who
is in incarcerated and can't pay will
that allow the um parent who has a
custody during that time period would
they get more Social Services while he's
incarcerated so that they can um
continue to
live this bill actually doesn't do
anything that we're not changing
anything by putting this bill on the law
is already set all we're doing is moving
it into the statute books okay it's
thank you it's already
there
representative deimon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question am I correct
that and please correct me if I'm not
that any erages incurred while the
incarcerated person is incarcerated just
goes
away I don't think so again there that
save that question because Susan Bon is
here and she's an attorney for the
dcyf and she's she's really brilliant on
the
stuff okay thank you thank you just just
save the questions for her thank you
thank you for your testimony and of
course the chair calls Susan
bristen to answer all these
questions don't you
what I leave the mic on for
good morning I'm Susan Bren I'm the
chief staff attorney for the office of
child support in the uh Department of
Health and Human Services and we are
here in support of this bill which has
been wonderfully described by
representative Bickford already
um as he said we we have the case of
lounder which was decided in 2014 which
basic basically
said um being incarcerated cannot be
held to be equivalent to being
voluntarily
underemployed um so we had it in in the
case so we've been going under that rule
since then but um our federal
counterparts have asked us to uh put it
actually in the guidelines because it's
required by the uh code of feder federal
regulations to be in the guidelines as
opposed to being just a case
so that's what that's what this bill
does
um I thought I would address the math
problem um if and I have no idea
how decisions are made of how anybody
becomes employed if they're incarcerated
but if they're making 725 an hour 40
hours a week which I doubt would happen
and then multiplying it by 4.33 because
that's how many weeks there are in a
year or sorry weeks there are in a month
the it comes out to
$1,255 70 Which is less than the minute
than the self-support reserve because
the self- support Reserve is $ 1397
which means it would be a $50 a month
order which is what would happen under
the for these types of cases anyway it
becomes a $50 it's a $50 a month order
that continues to acre while the person
is incarcerated then when they get out
they're supposed to report back in to
let us know what's happening
and hopefully they're working cuz
hopefully they're coming out they're on
parole they have to have a job they have
to have a you know place to live they
let us know where they're working we
recalculate their child support and move
on from
there
representative
Gibbons thank you Mr chairman and you
are absolutely correct it is
representative given despite what my
name plate says um
I am just wondering
uh maybe this is a question more for CJ
but uh for the criminal justice
committee but is it
still is it still on uh applications for
work that you have to disclose if you've
been
incarcerated and if so then isn't that a
barrier for them getting a job once
they're out of prison and if so then
that it presents a barrier for paying
child support So shouldn't we get rid of
that I don't I don't know I don't think
it's a requirement that it has to be on
an application for for employment with
regards to I think that they can ask and
then you can answer or not answer but
I'm not sure
how somebody's choice
to get in trouble with the law then
somehow makes it so that they don't have
to uh pay child support right a lot of
this all has to do with ability to pay
which is what one of the the things that
our federal counterparts have been um
asking us
to concentrate on and that uh we do a
three-year review people can ask for a
three-year review if they're not on
tanif tanif cases are reviewed every
three years to make sure that the the
order is the right size for for the
parties based on their circumstances so
this is part of that in that somebody
who's incarcerated who has no income or
minimum income their order should be
right sized
to the minimum or it can actually be
zero we don't we ask for a $50 a month
order the courts can order
zero and then have it have it be
elsewhere and as representative Bickford
said that um it's not doesn't
automatically go to $50 a month we would
have to do a analysis to make sure that
there there weren't other um income out
there that would mean that there should
actually be a child support order that
we and hopefully one that we could
actually access while somebody's in
incarcerated representative deimon thank
you Mr
chairman so am I correct that this
particular bill will
only change the provision that an
incarcerated individual will not be held
in
contempt for not paying child's support
while
incarcerated is that pretty much what
this bill
says I I don't think it has anything to
do with contempt but it it basically
says that it changes the let me give you
an example it's probably helpful in the
olden days before the lounder case
people who were incarcerated would file
a motion for modification for the court
saying I don't have income because I'm
incarcerated and the courts were
required to have a hearing on it and
then would say you're voluntarily under
unemployed because you voluntarily did
something to make yourself incarcerated
we're not changing your child support go
back to jail and so then it would
continue to increase at whatever
whatever number it is all this is saying
is that
the his a somebody who's incarcerated is
can't be considered voluntarily
underemployed so it allows it to go
allows the order to go to that $50 a
month or zero whatever the Court decides
is the appropriate number M while
they're incarcerated and then once
they're un incarcerated we review it
again and hopefully they've they're
working and we can put in a more
uh gain Full Employment and you know
more income for the the uh family thank
you am I correct Council I'm assuming
that if an individual is now led out of
prison and cannot get a job because a
lot of people do not want to hire xcon
and can demonstrate good faith effort in
trying to get a job but still has no
money from a job that's not what we're
dealing with here at all that's
something else that's correct literally
correct this is only having to deal with
people who are actually incarcerated
thank you representative Vice chairman
long thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um so I owe $150 a
week I get incarcerated do you have
access to my accounts savings accounts
assets um do you have access to
that um it's possible it it it really
depends factually on what's Happening um
we do have the ability to lean people's
bank
accounts but it has to be over a certain
amount right and then we have to know
about it um to to do that but yes we do
we do still have the ability to
enforce while somebody's incarcerated so
if they owe a lot of money coming in we
can still enforce if if somebody um
inherits a lot of money while they're
incarcerated we can put a lean on that
to pay pay off so follow up follow up uh
thank you Mr chairman um
so so this the change of this language
allows me incarcerated to modify
correct so if I owe if I owe $150 a
month and I have um I have $30,000 in my
savings
account uh that you don't know about uh
I could modify to the $50 a
month and take it from that $30,000
savings
account I mean that that that's what I'm
trying to figure out is this an
advantage for being incarcerated to
modify uh when I have assets I well I
suppose it's possible if you're going to
lie to the court when you f when you
file for a motion I'm incarcerated so
well but when when chances are yeah when
you file a motion for
modification you have to fill out a
financial affidavit under oath yeah that
asks you about that type of things okay
I would also assume that your ex or
other people in your life might know
about things like that and we might find
out and then so it's not an automatic
you actually have to have a hearing on
it okay right all right thank
you
any other
questions saying none thank you so much
you're very welcome is it the what do
you
think what do you think folks we want to
go on to exec or you want to
not up meanings that's
exact okay I closed the hearing on House
Bill 1340 and I open an exact session on
and the chair calls on representative
Bickford for a
motion I make a motion to um ought to
pass on HB 1340 could I have a second
preferably from a person whose name I
know representative
Gibbons yes I would like to second that
okay any
discussion representative Gibbons thank
you Mr chairman um to address uh
representative long um I suppose someone
could maybe get incarcerated just to
address their child support but I really
don't expect that someone would do that
because it would follow them there would
be so many negative uh secondary effects
to being incarcerated I I just I mean I
mean just because someone can doesn't
mean someone should and I I just don't
think think an average person would want
to go that
route yeah I'm not I'm not saying that
somebody wants to get incarcerated to
lower but if I get incarcerated I have
an advantage of lowering my modification
because this is
involuntary um you know so that's what
I'm saying if I owe 150 and I'm
incarcerated I'll take advantage of
going to 50 I don't have a job and I
have $30,000 on my savings account
yeah so but I wonder how many times
we've ever heard somebody on a happy
little sunny afternoon say I know I'm
going to go break the law so I don't
have to pay child support I I don't
think
so that's exactly what I was getting at
was that I don't think okay yeah I I was
not thinking that someone would actively
break the law just to get out of child
support that just doesn't seem normal
anyone else wish to weigh in
representative Panic thank you for
taking my question my or my comment
there comments yeah comments um I think
this is a way to protect
the person being incarcerated from from
us taking blood out of a
rock I mean if you don't have the money
you don't have the money and once they
do get out of jail we want to be able to
get them back on track and I think this
brings them to that point Thank
You
representative Gibbons yes thank you Mr
chairman and to address that point
that's that's why I brought up that
maybe we should make sure that the
criminal maybe we need to do it next
legislative year but the make sure that
the criminal justice system does not ask
about uh incarceration on job
applications because if that becomes a
barrier to them getting a job then how
are they going to get back on track on
child support so this is a good question
for another day perhaps it a question
for another day come up before
representative bigford you had your hand
up oh uh thank you Mr chairman I just
want from the Supreme Court decision it
does say this does however preclude a
court from determining that a parent has
remaining sources of income such that
modification is unwarranted so that's so
other income y can be applied but what
we're looking at here is child support
is uh
generally uh set by earnings not your
assets thank you uh but they can tap
into them if they need it those assets
anyone
else the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1340 exclud inclusion
of incarceration as voluntary
unemployment for purposes of calculating
child support moved by representative
Bickford seconded by representative
Gibbons would the clerk please call the
role chairman peon
yes Vice chairman long
yes representative
disimone representative bfid yes
representative
Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative
grman yes representative LC yes
representative Patrina will be voting
yes representative
Perez yes yes representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons yes
representative Raymond yes 16 to zero
any OB objection to consent this is
uh not an early bill so uh I can go on
to consent representative bford if you
would have the committee report to me
before you leave today or
sooner now there we go
huh it
out I missed that laugh last
week
okay good this uh concludes the EXA
session on House Bill
1340 and uh what are we doing today and
now I open the hearing on House Bill
1308 relative to parent access to
Children's Library records and
representative
corello did I get that right is that a
good Italian cor
yell she's
also thank you Mr
chair and committee members
I'm not used to being on this side this
is new for
me scary my name no reminds me when I
was a teacher so okay um my name is
Arlene corello I represent
Atkinson the purpose of
h308 is to allow allow parents to know
what library books their children have
checked out at both public and school
libraries any publicly funded libraries
currently Library circulation records
are considered confidential for all
users so that includes
minors as a public library employee
myself I can attest to the fact that
being unable to tell parents what books
their kids have checked out leads to
some very awkward
situations uh that is why I initially
thought this bill would be a good
idea a lot of these situations involve
overdue books I'm not going to get into
a lot of
anecdotal situations but just a few to
give you an idea of what I have to go
through each day at the front desk of
the library I often have to tell parents
that they're children owe fines because
it's usually the parents who end up
paying them but by law I cannot tell
them what the fines are for even though
as I just said they usually end up
paying
them then there was the time I had a pay
Patron who was looking all over her
house for a library book that her child
had misplaced but I couldn't tell her
what the title was so she didn't even
know what book she was looking for there
was a kid who was listening to a long
series of audio books and he lost track
of which ones he had already listened to
uh his mom just wanted to help he want
she wanted to know which ones he had
previously checked out but I couldn't
even tell her
that the parents for the most part react
with disbelief in these situations and
as I said I could go on and on with
examples but this is not the only reason
I'm putting the bill forward it was the
initial impetus for the
idea as we all know we live in a time
when there is an increasing amount of
concern over controversial materials
kept in
libraries a couple of weeks ago the
house education committee which I serve
on right over there across the hall
heard testimony on hb1
1419 a bill regarding the prohibition of
obscene materials in school
libraries one of the opponents of this
bill in defending the continued
inclusion of such material asserted I
quote it's up to us as parents to know
what our kids are
reading although I disagreed with him on
the the bill he opposed and I support it
that's a different Bill not the issue
today I completely agreed with this
particular statement he made
in a similar way last September Dr Nancy
pack the director of Alabama's Public
Library System defended the library's
collection development policies in a
letter to Governor K Ivy and this is
what she wrote Alabama's public
libraries will always value parental
involvement in overseeing the material
their children's borrow their children
borrow she later wrote that the
responsibility for determining the
suitability of libr liary materials for
children lies primarily with parents or
Guardians although we might not see eye
to eye on other issues I share Dr P's
support again of the parents' role in
guiding their children's reading
selections to fulfill this role more
effectively parents need to know what
books their children have checked out
and this is especially important in
school libraries where parents are not
usually present with their children as
they often are in public
libraries the New Hampshire library
trustees Association manual highlights I
quote the responsibility and the rights
of all parents and Guardians to guide
their own children's use of the library
and its resources and services my own
public library in Atkinson asserts as
many libraries do in their policies that
I quote again it is the responsibility
of parents and Guardians to Monitor and
improve the selection of materials made
by children
with such Universal affirmation of the
need for Parental involvement on both
sides with all these
controversial issues involving books
right now all I could find was Universal
affirmation every organization
saying that parents need to know they
need to be involved with their
children's
reading
activities so HB 1308 should not be
controvers IAL at
all in order for parents to be fully
involved in upholding their
responsibility to monitor their
children's use of Library materials
which everything I could find said this
is a good thing they must have access to
their kids Library
records so the elephant in the room I
know the primary objection to this bill
will be that some children especially
older children may not want their
parents to know what books they are
reading and I certainly appreciate the
need for
privacy but I don't think that privacy
rights should extend to a person's use
of
materials that have been paid for by
someone else and that's exactly what's
going on here it's the parents who pay
the taxes that pay for the books okay
the minors they pray you know through
their property
taxes the children don't financially
support the library
and there are alternatives If the child
really doesn't want to know want the
parent to know that they're reading
something the parent you know might have
some issues with well these this is
normally older children older children
can get a job a paper route they can
earn money they can go to the bookstore
they can buy it on Amazon and if they
can't do that they can go to the library
and read whatever they want with nobody
knowing they just can't check it out and
like I said before the parents are the
ones who ultimately even though there's
no statute
saying that they are responsible
financially this is what ends up
happening they end
up paying the overdue fines um and in
the end they they're the ones paying for
the books with their property
taxes so um I'll I'll leave the rest for
questions I have a lot of information
here so but I want to address um but I I
just want to end by saying that I ask
you to help add New Hampshire to a
growing number of states we would not be
the first state to do this um that are
supporting such Common Sense
legislation please pass HB 1308 not only
to help facilitate Library operations
but also to support parental involvement
in children children's reading Pursuits
and I just also want to make one note
that a big supporter of this bill and a
co-sponsor was representative Mike Drago
from Raymond New Hampshire and he
couldn't be here here today because of
his business he's a landscaper he had to
go salt the weather and all um so I just
wanted to let you know that he sent his
testimony via email I'm not going to
read it I thought at first then I've
already taken enough of your time so
please pay particular attention to that
um testimony because he's the father of
five children and he uses the library a
lot and so I will be happy to take your
questions and hopefully be able to
answer them representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you represent for taking my question my
my concern is um the library Gathering a
database of all of these parents uh in
advance and I'm particularly concerned
with uh identifying parents who have
custodial rights some you know as in
schools for example one parent has
access to information other parents
don't uh will libraries be able to have
all of that information um will this
incur uh extra cost and a burden on
libraries to do these types of
things I can't think of any cost it
would infer because I'm going from my
own experience working in libraries I
mean in a way it would make my job
easier so
um there would be that that I can think
of no
other negative financial
burden follow
up okay thank you I'd like to uh just
restate my question I'm concerned about
custodial uh rights that parents have
for example when there's a divorce one
parent may have access say to school
records uh dad comes into the school and
wants to know what's going on with their
kid and the school is not obligated
because that particular parent doesn't
have the rights and so my concern is the
custodial rights that individual parents
have one parent may have legal rights to
access information where others don't
and that really is the heart of my
question how do we you know how does
someone come into a library and say I'm
the father of soand so and I want to
know what my kid is looking at okay um
just to clarify so if if a parent
doesn't have custodial rights is there
some concern that if that parent did
obtain the information there might be a
negative consequence to the the child no
I believe there's some liability issues
on the part of the library if the
library discerns information that
they're not uh allowed to give because
that particular parent doesn't have the
right to have that information so here
you have a librarian who is trying to
decide you know am I legally obligated
to give this particular parent
information maybe I can give it to Mom
but not to Dad and how would the
librarian know that it would put the
library I think in in a situation where
there be some
liability so I'm not a lawyer most of us
reps aren't you bring up some good
points but by bringing up this sort of
situation though for me I I I thought
one you know one of the objections to
This was um something that does come up
often in things that may be considered
parental right spells where um a parent
May let's say the non-custodial
parent um may not be happy with what
that parent sees the child is reading
and maybe even abuses them physically
and my and I don't know if this goes to
your question like I said I'm not a
lawyer so some of these points you bring
up about custodial you know it's a
little Beyond me um uh but the intent of
the bill is all all good and not you
know certainly not to
um put children In Harm's Way um but you
know one of the things um just as an
analogy children get report
cards maybe they get a bunch of D's and
an F you still send the report card
home you know
with the argument of child safety it
could be that you know well maybe we
shouldn't send the report cards home
because if they have a bad report card
they the parent might beat the kid up I
want to follow right up on what
representative patrino said uh don't
Librarians uh or Library Personnel have
to know those
cases when a child of tender age is
going to be picked up at the library and
some parents some people do not have the
right to pick up a child at the library
or at the elementary school uh but so in
a situation a family disruption
situation wouldn't the library have to
know that right now this parent is not
allowed to pick up um Billy or Susie so
it seems to me you're already doing some
of those
things you know I speak from my
experience so I brought this forward and
um you're talking about issues that you
know maybe different larger libraries
you know I I know all these uh I know
most of the parents who come in um and I
I see your concerns and I I honestly you
know don't know how thoroughly I can
speak to your questions
so I can look into it
more if this is a big concern if there's
some need for an amendment my point was
isn't it more wor to find out which
parent can get the list of the kids
books checked out isn't it already a
concern in many and I take your point
larger Librarians libraries where uh
picking up a kid at the library May
involv the library staff in making sure
they don't allow the kid to go off with
the wrong well one of the things though
that libraries encourage and a lot of
the policies that I saw pertain to the
fact that you you you need to to oversee
your child you don't just you know this
whole idea of like thinking like oh you
just drop them off and and um the
everything I kept reading was how
they're like you should be involved and
you know oversee the activities and it's
not just like a drop off place so you
can you know go have a break drop your
kids off okay thank you representative
Perez thank you Mr Sher and thank you
for taking my question um more than a
question is I'm a little concerned um as
you know maybe some of you know um I'm a
a survivor of sexual assult um from one
of my parents from my from my dad and
this is very concerning because my dad
was a well-known
architect back in the days since he was
a well-known they allow him to pick me
up from the school from different
areas even know that he was the
abuser my mom which she wasn't a
professional person was not allowing to
have the same information is my dad who
would he abuse it so I'm I'm very
concerned um why would you tell of
victims and survivors like myself that
you know yes you want to give that
information to parents but we need to be
very
careful uh about what information or who
is getting that information like I said
you know as a Survivor I'm very
concerned about this
bill so it gets back to what I was
saying before um that it your concern is
safety the child's safety that's a big
concern um now I bring up my analogy
before about report cards just a
question it custodi with custodial
rights are they not allowed to see the
child's report
card
okay a question from another member
representative Greg please thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
representative and presenting your bill
you know I have one question I know that
you've said a few times that one thing
that you keep running into is the
language that the responsibility for
determining uh the suitability of
material should be with the parents and
stuff do you think that instead of
intending for people to be reporting on
the children that maybe they're
intending that parents have
conversations with their
children
I I certainly believe that CH that
parents should be having reading to
their children um younger children um so
I'm in agreement with that but what I
have put forward is that there are just
certain logistical situations I gave
some examples
um also it's you know let's say a child
is or a parent comes into the library
with a bunch of you know has a larger
family and representative Dro could have
spoken to to this and it's sort of a
chaotic environment and um you kind of
can lose track children get their own
library cards at the age of five um so
uh you can lose track and it's important
I think in order to have those
conversations I think it's important to
know what the books this the child has
out followup representative Greg as a
librarian are you not able to talk with
the child then and say the book that you
are reading or the book that you have
lost is barenstein bears go to Camp are
you not able to tell the child that you
said that you were not able to tell the
parent right it's the parent who
primarily is taking care and
facilitating on a daily basis I'm
working with families and it's I I don't
really engage with the individual the
child sometimes is unable to you know
sometimes the parents come in alone
they're just returning books you know
the child's not with them but to you
know engage in some sort of transaction
with the child pertaining to Circular
ulation uh issues seems um not realistic
clarification representative
ball thank you chairman um could you
please explain to me when a library card
is given to a minor
um do the parents have to give
permission for the child to have that
library card many libraries do require
that um mine mine does does not but
usually there's a there's a parent
the parent is with the child for the
most part the child doesn't just come in
and sign up for a library card the
parent I need to use in fact the um I
need to have the parents driver's
license so I guess in a way that is the
consent that I that I am using the
parents driver's license to sign the
child up for a library card follow
follow up so that's my that's exactly my
point so if you could just to confirm my
understanding you do have to check with
the parents so the parent has to give
permission for the child to get the to
have a library card because the child
the parent is going to have to pay the
fines so there the parent has that's the
that's the understanding with the
library sort of I did look into statute
on the requirement to for the parent to
pay fines and that's actually not in
there but many Library policies do say I
found a few very easily and if I dug
deeper I would think there's many more
libraries that specifically say that the
parent is responsible for the library
fines
so they're part of the
contract is BAS yeah in a sense I mean
they have to give I cannot give a child
a library card without seeing a parents
driver's license and also usually
especially with the younger children who
may not have a cell phone the phone
number on the account is the parents
number this leads to some of those
awkward situations where I call up and
say something is terribly overdue and I
can't tell them what's overdue when the
parent answers I'm not going to and
maybe to kind of go back to
representative Greg's point it's not
like I'm going to talk to the child on
the phone you know maybe if it's a
teenager sure your book's overdue you
have a cell phone but not not uh younger
so thank you uh
Representative giord no R I'm getting
gford though you yes thank you sorry
thank you Mr chairman um thank you for
coming before us and I didn't realize
today I brought my re
my real librarian bag um are they
overdue as my lunch bag so one of my
concerns is the
liability for the Librarians as well um
in terms of the libraries libraries are
our safe zones um and when we think
about the kids the mo more vulnerable
kids would you believe that Librarians
don't have access access to those
custodial agreements knowing which
parent um Li libraries don't hold that
information right now so we would be if
if this were to pass we would have to
create a
mechanism to give Librarians that
information that's very private so for
example I actually have guardianship of
my 19-year-old son so when I had to go
to the library and present that legal
information to them they did not have
that information for my 19-year-old son
that I have guardianship of so this
would be a
whole Vault of information that would
need to be brought to libraries across
the
state what mechanism would that go
through I cannot speak to that I'm not
prepared to speak to that directly and
you've bought up a couple of you who
brought up this issue and I would
certainly be willing to look into it
more and um you know you know if there
was some amendment that could address
your concerns I would be very open to
that
so representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um my question is about um line
six on your um Bell it says such records
include but are not limited to library
information system and archival Records
um and so my question is kind of a
follow-up to um representative balls you
mentioned that you require a driver's
license so what type of information is
in your library system computer that a
non-custodial or even a parent that has
a um protective order preventing them
from accessing the location of the other
parent what kind of information is in
the system that that this bill would
authorize them to now have well there's
just basic contact information when I
sign someone up for a card and then
every piece of material that gets
checked in or out there's a record that
that transaction
happened and those Rec I'm sorry follow
up Mr thank you those records for a
Minor's library card would be the
custodial parents contact information
correct yes okay thank
you representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question and thank you for being a
librarian it's an important job I really
appreciate what you do um and I just
have a question
um um is
it access to Children's Library records
like the children's library or the
records of the child what the just
basically what the child has checked out
okay thank you and may I please have one
follow up um what age are we are we
referring to here what age of child are
we referring to is it that's covered by
the bill um minor so up to
age 18 you know until age until age 18
thank
you representative
Panic thank you for allowing me to take
uh ask a question
um our children have access to the
internet and all I hear on the news is
that monitor your child's internet
access and what's being put out there in
front of them and then I am hearing
stories here with this bill being
proposed that oh no we don't want the
parents to have access it seems like
we've got a a dichotomy going on over
here and it's like should we be
monitoring what our children are being
um exposed to on the internet
and then we're not supposed to
be monitoring what's going on in the
libraries which is I I just can't see
that as being two separate things and I
think that this bill is addressing one
of those
issues and
it's a way for parents to protect their
children on what they want exposure to
correct I agree with what you're saying
and and
for the most part it protect I would
bring this forward because it helps with
what you're saying um I I there's so
many
um you know you bring up the internet
and that's really hard to control
because they can access it anywhere and
on their phone and all um the library
building is something that we can have
more um control over
so I really just have the best interest
of the children in
mind repres representative
bigford uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um now you in
uh line 12 you say parent or guardian of
the minor but how would it work if that
was stricken and you put in person the
person's sponsoring the library card
because as you pointed out earlier
that's the person that's responsible for
paying the debt it needs to be a parent
or our Guardian
though it needs to be you can't just
have any adult it's a f you know family
member it would be a parent of
Guardian yes right yes so therefore it's
it's there
it's the person
or because you've already got that
policy in place that has I me
all that I mean that is basically the
line that's being added um and it does
reflect some of the language of what's
in there
already so I'm not sure how to answer
your question can I try again yes uh
thank you Mr chairman as you pointed out
the child gets a library card because a
parent sponsors them
right right I you could use that word
sponsor um so that would be the person
that should I would think uh the library
should be responsible too because they
take a child takes books out doesn't
return them you're going to expect that
sponsor to pay the bill so and you don't
need other parents involved then it's
the one that gives the library card to
so it's the one who initially right so I
think in a way what you're saying kind
of maybe anwers some of the other
concerns about custodial thank you for
for doing that because it does um
address that then the person who comes
in and then representative ball had
asked questions about how do you get the
library card and it's the custodial
parent coming in with the driver's
license so okay I hope that I hope then
that clarifies some of the other
questions that were asked that I feel
like I didn't answer adequately only
because I'm not a lawyer and so some of
this uh language and and all is um not
in my area of
expertise representative Nelson hi thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my um question um representative um do
all um I and I'm sorry I'm I don't know
this answer to this question um but
that's why it's a question
are I don't I don't excuse my ignorance
um do libraries across the state utilize
the same um system uh computer system oh
no there's all different ones and so um
what level of archival information do um
like do certain libraries have more
capability to access archival
information than others or I'm just
trying to wrap my head around
um are we going to set ourselves up for
um some libraries to have to change
their computer programs to you know okay
I will admit I'm I'm have I'm not a
career like lifelong librarian expert
this is I was actually a teacher for
many years and after covid I left that
and I became just a a employee of a
local public library assistant director
working at the front desk so I'm not an
expert and I feel like I'm not now I is
the State Library hello I've met you
before the state Li maybe the state
librarian could I didn't know if he was
going to speak but maybe he can answer
some of your technical questions okay so
yeah representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again representative for taking my
question you did mention something in
your testimony and I didn't quite pick
up on it so I just wanted to clarify
ification what is the situation when um
anyone enters a library and walks down
uh and starts perusing the shelves to
take a book off the shelf open it up and
start reading something that maybe in
this instance the child should not be
looking at I mean how do we police that
control that I mean a child can walk
into a library and just take a book so
what you're saying is that there's
inappropriate material in libraries no
what I'm saying no no what I'm saying is
what your concern is that there's
inappropriate materials in the library
that CH should not have access to is
what I'm hearing so my concern is if
that's the case how do we prevent
children from accessing what you refer
to as inappropriate material by simply
just walking in after school walking
down the shelves taking a book down and
standing in the aisle for about 10
minutes just kind of flipping through
the pages not even taking the book out
how do we how do we prevent that and
because you did make reference to that I
thinking your testimony and they didn't
quite pick up on the oh um I think what
I was saying was that if older
children didn't want their parents to
know what books they're reading they
they can go into the library and just
not check them out the minute they check
the book out my contention is that the
the sponsoring parent who is you know
with the library the driver's license um
they're the property owner they're
paying the taxes that buy the books so
they should be able to know what books
the child takes out so
um the child if the child doesn't take a
book
out and remains in the library they have
privacy they um but what concerns me
more is your question because you use
this term
inappropriate and I think that is a term
that needs to be defined by the parent
maybe that you know we have so much
controversy now about inappropriate
materials and um I think both sides can
agree I read all that stuff about how
both sides were saying parents need to
be involved parents need to be involved
so um the parents are the ones that
should then be defining for their child
what they think is
appropriate do you want to follow up
follow up than you yeah just for
clarification inappropriate material I
believe is what you had testified to so
I was basically using your concern not
my concern okay mising some people think
things are inappropriate for the
purposes of this bill we're discussing
right here I think it should be that the
whole point is that the parents need to
be involved because they need to
be you know guiding their children in
what they think is
appropriate any other
questions thank you for your testimony
and uh given the I'm
sorry representative sidel you are back
lit and I didn't see you
okay thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um in going along
with representative Bickford's um
comment on line 12 would you be at all
interested in being able to amend that
line to make it so that it's just the
parent that gives and in so doing to
address the concerns that to me seem to
be the main stumbling block a little bit
for some of you if there was some sort
of way to clarify that sure that sounds
like a great
idea thank you for your
testimony thank you all the education
committee is probably probably wondering
where the heck I am because we're in I
was like I just had to step out for a
minute all right we are going to now
move into the 4minute drill and that is
not uncommon in most committees and it
is enforced uh make your point in in 4
minutes no longer or you'll lose your
mic and then that will give an
opportunity for a few questions and that
should actually pushes past 12 noon
chair next recognizes I think this is um
is it Renee
Mallet come on
up and your first test at sitting at the
witness table
is no that's the second one
yeah well done it it's red I don't feel
self-righteous about that because I went
to testify in another committee and I
forgot to turn it on to uh this is the
first time I've had to come up and
testify so I'm I'm a newbie um my name
is Renee Mallet I live in Windom New
Hampshire I am a former Library trustee
a currently on the board of directors
for the New Hampshire library trustee
Association and I am also the parent of
five children which Apparently one of
the co co-sponsors is um a lot of you
asked questions that were kind of at the
heart of what I wanted to testify
to um you know sorry I take a lot of
notes going back to sort of the the
beginning when we you know when the
representative was reading sort of these
things about how parents should be
involved with their kids and um a lot of
that language actually comes from what
in library world we call the unintended
children policy um I can't speak for her
library but most of the libraries in the
state do not allow unattended children
in the library so it's not just a matter
of the parent has to be there to sign
the child up for a library card the
parents are expected to be with the
children and be involved with the
children while they're at the library it
is not a place where you're supposed to
drop your kid off and come in later and
say hey what were they doing what were
they reading
um these policies can vary in libraries
across the state um I live in Windam and
our policy is pretty typical I think for
most libraries uh Windam actually does
not allow children under 11 in the
library at all without a parent and
again that parent is expected to be
involved with the child they're not
supposed to you know go look at their
own books and the kid wanders around and
is doing anything um as we've said you
know parents have to sign their children
up for a library card um in Windom
between the ages of 11 and 14 kids are
still only expected to only spend about
an hour alone in the library um so at
that point we're starting to talk about
kids you know Windom like many New
Hampshire towns is not walkable um I'm
an adult I couldn't walk to our library
sadly I wish we had sidewalks and could
I would love it um so in order to for a
kid to even get to the library a parent
or someone has to be bringing them there
or they have to be old enough to have a
driver's license and a car and go
themselves um and for me especially as a
parent with five kids this comes
down it is not a parental right issue
it's a parental responsibility issue we
should know our kids if we don't trust
our kids to follow our family values or
expectations why would we give them a
car and a driver's license and let them
go wherever they want and you know and
and I think it is important to say you
know uh being from a big family I know
one of the representatives arguments was
you know it's it's harder if you have a
big family to keep track of what
everybody's reading and doing and um I
don't know I talking about what we're
reading and the media we're accessing
for us is a family thing we sit at the
dinner table and we talk about what
we're reading and you know what we've
done with our day so I I certainly for
myself do not
find number of kids
detriment um I did just want to say I I
appr appreciated the comment that maybe
this could be amended in a way to make
it safer for children but I did want to
say that just because somebody is a
parent and signs their kid up for a
library card does not mean that later on
there couldn't be a family disruption
situation custody can change parent
rights can change you're putting a big
onus on the taxpayers and on Library
employees to keep track of legal matters
and and frankly I think it's a burden
for residents in New Hampshire if you're
going through through a family
disruption situation if you're getting a
divorce if you're you know have domestic
violence the last thing you want to
think about is oh and now I've got to go
update my kids library card
um I just think that ultimately I think
this does cost it costs our libraries in
towns for legal liabilities libraries
will have to update their systems to
keep track of records and custody and I
I thank you thank you for your testimony
I do have a question for you if you'll
take one
um you said I think I heard you say no
unintended children allowed in the
library is that up to age 11 or is that
Beyond like I said it can vary by
Library um in the town I live in it's
under 11 parents have to be there so on
the surface that could mean therefore
the parents are already there watching
what kid books the kids want to take out
but it doesn't demand that you ID people
to make sure the person the adult
tending to the child is in fact a parent
it could be a teacher it could be a
coach it could be an advocate and so
that child could walk out of the library
with various things and the parent
doesn't know it even though the child is
tender aged um I know from my
familiarity with our unattended children
policy is that it does say specifically
that a parent or Guardian is expected to
be with the child um no know it's not
policed um again because our Librarians
have no mechanism in place in order to
track that sort of information um but
ours says actually quite specifically I
think it might even be bolded the
library is not acting in the place of
the parent a parent or Guardian is
expected to be with the children okay
thank you other
questions seeing none thank you hey for
a rookie you did
good and look that she turned it off
when she was done w
the chair next recognizes Karen ISB ISB
isid all
right but you found the button yeah push
the button um my name is Karen islab I
am the head of Youth Services for the
Manchester City library and I am
concerned about one word in the um well
more concerned about the impact of the
what the word Services is now does that
mean that we have to as Librarians when
the kids come to programs do we have to
make we have to write down every little
thing that they do because that is going
to take so much time um I'm going to
give you a little bit very quick um
summary of how many programs we do once
a month or monthly programs at the
Library our library our two buildings we
do three story times a week so that is
for four weeks that's 12 story times we
do two other monthly story times well
the story times for our P um attendance
is about 50 to 60
kids I can't run around after 5 year
olds for all all 50 60 kids monthly um
story times that's average is about 30 a
month
two Elementary experiments stem programs
that averages 30 to 40 kids a month one
special toddler program that can go
anywhere from 60 to 80
people um one legal program 30 to 50
kids weekly teen
programs at both buildings maybe 15 20
25 um two monthly
um movie
maybe 10 12 15
kids and this is a and I'm also
look thinking about once they leave the
program do we have to follow them and
say oh this child played with a PL toy
this one did this um we also have two
wial reading programs going on which
have six different passive programs that
they can do we have scavenger hunts for
the kids we have crafts that they can
do um then then also does the services
incl include all our
Outreach for us we do 12 to 14 different
Outreach programs that include story
times stem programs Escape rooms with
different groups we also have a
bookmobile how am I supposed to keep
track of 800 kids that come to a
bookmobile
event that's where my concern is oh I
also do a a all story time
too um
it's it's unreasonable if we have to do
that we would need to increase this our
staff maybe triple our staff which means
there's an added cost and at a time
where libraries some libraries are
looking at a budget cut that's not
feasible
also there is no one someone asked about
is there a one system for all the
libraries no there's not some libraries
may not even be automated yet to handle
this doing this stuff we're not capable
of doing
it
so um you got 45 seconds um also our
unattended policy does required it has
to be a parent or a guardian and we are
um eight and under half parents have to
be with the child in the library they
cannot be left
alone will you take questions sure I'll
take questions questions representative
ball thank you chairman parison um so
you mentioned that you have many uh
programs at your school in my particular
town in Salem our library is right next
to the um pretty much next to the Middle
School yes so my question is if a child
um signs up for an event or the parent
signs them up for an event
um I would imagine that they get signed
in yep in at some way
and then the maybe the parent later on
wants to check and make sure did my
child actually show up for this event or
are they in other words it's parents are
trying to monitor them because the child
walks there how do they know they really
went the previous person said our
library unfortunately everybody pretty
much has to be dropped off by a parent
so the parents know that if they sign a
child up for an event the only way
they're getting there is for them to be
dropped off the younger kids the parents
the Guardians parents have to stay with
them so follow up but I'm referring to
middle school so we're talking about
children that are over your age yeah lot
our middle school programs I'm going 90%
of these kids are um dropped off by
their parents they have to our middle
schools are nowhere near our library so
the parents literally have to go pick up
the kids bring them to the library for
the program that they have signed up for
and then they have to come back and pick
them
up just representative
Raymond thank you what is the library's
responsibility for supervising kids who
show up at the library so I have
teenagers now um and I can't I can't
think of a time that I have dropped them
off at a public place like a library or
a museum or even a store and let them
just wander for hours but what is a
library's responsibility as opposed to
other places like a museum or a store to
supervise kids who are left there so
when I say the parents drop the kids off
some of them will some of them will come
stop and drop you know get out of their
car walk the kids into the program check
in and then just they're there some
sometimes it's the oh my goodness I'm
trying to figure out how to say some
parents will stay and they'll stay
upstairs and wait for the parent the
children some children say Mom and Dad I
don't need you to stay they'll go
quickly run do grocery shopping they'll
come right back
so follow up follow up thank you so in
those circumstances where a parent has
dropped a kid off and left the
building what's the responsibility under
the job descriptions or the rules for
the library for the library to take
responsibility for supervising those
children like is that a paid Babysitting
Service like what no so what I'm saying
is these are mostly for the programs now
if they're coming in for books the
parent are
there
but I mean we have some that'll some
kids will just some parents will just
quickly go do an errand or go pick up
another child and come back so last CL
and we have we have a staff member in
that build in that program so last
clarifying question yes so it's the
parents responsibility to determine the
maturity of their child to be
unsupervised in your public
space I mean that's yes okay thank you
I have a question for you um stipulating
your comment about line seven that the
word Services yes could open all kinds
of things I will stipulate to that what
if it was just reduced to checking out
library books would you have an
objection to the parents knowing what
books a minor child who was brought and
picked up at the library by somebody
other than the child's parents was piing
out no I mean that would make our life a
little bit easier okay thank you any
other questions seeing none thank you so
much and the chair recognizes Amber
Coughlin from Lebanon libraries and four
minutes you pass first test thank you
welcome uh my name's Amber Coughlin I'm
the children's librarian at Lebanon
libraries uh in Lebanon New Hampshire
and I'm opposed to this bill um as you
know New Hampshire has pretty great laws
protecting the confidentially
confidentiality of Library users records
and as such libraries tend to collect
just the information about our patrons
that we need to conduct business every
day and nothing more many of the
activities in fact I would say the bulk
of the activi that people engage in in
the library do not generate records um
on at my library on any given day you
know in addition to checking out books
and materials uh we could be hosting a
music Pro program for toddlers or a
blues guitar Workshop that's
intergenerational um we might offer
crafts that you take home with you or um
you might do a craft program right in
the library we might have musical
performances we might have yoga we might
have animals there that you know for
kids to learn about Raptors or
amphibians there are all kinds of things
happening inside the library and outside
the library we have Community Gardens we
have a wonderful Green Space that people
come and enjoy their lunch on beautiful
days our WiFi is all around the building
so sometimes people are just checking
their email in the parking lot before
the library is even open um it's a
public space um lots of people just stop
by just to browse for a few minutes
while they're waiting for the bus they
don't even necessarily have a library
card
um it's a busy Place uh there's a lot
going on but it's a public place our
space and our Stacks are open to anyone
and everyone we don't surveil the stacks
to see who has taken a given title off
the shelf we don't have the capacity to
conduct these investigations into who
might be a person who is legal legally
entitled to see a child's records and
who does not and of course I don't need
to remind you that children are not
always safe with their parents um and
families struggling with domestic
violence often depend on carefully
maintaining strict standards of privacy
in order to keep themselves safe from
their abusers we keep minimal records
for patrons out of respect for their
individual privacy which is so important
for freedom of inquiry freedom of
thought we consider our policies really
carefully they're not made just
willy-nilly
um I do hope you will consider these
issues um and understand why I am
strongly opposed to this bill um we have
tried to develop our circulation
policies with maximal flexibility for uh
parents and families there is no um
barrier to a family opening up a family
card that maybe has a single email
address attached to it so that you know
if you do have five kids and you don't
want to keep track of five separate
library cards and and you just want one
list of everything your family has
checked out that is easily available but
if a person any Patron opens up an IND
indidual library card by themselves with
nobody else's contact information
attached to it we only give out that
identifying information to the holder of
that card thank you very much um you
keep minimal records as a person who's a
total scatter brain I really like that
that's why I have smart people on going
down the rows here uh but you do keep a
record yes of who checks out what one
book else you could not find them or
retrieve your book and so if this were
changed to just children taking out
library books and nothing else would you
still have an objection I would have an
objection okay thank you other questions
representative Raymond thank you um and
thank you for taking my question ma
you've jogged my thought on something
and so frequently my um 13-year-old who
is a scatter brain uh like chairman
describes himself has lost her card or
doesn't have her card so we frequently
take out books on whoever happens to be
the person checking out with her which
would be me um would a parent like
myself have access to that record if if
it was checked out under my card as a
parent Oh Oh you mean if if your say
your daughter checked a book out on your
library card yes oh yeah I mean that's
your library card so you if you are
generous enough to offer your library
card to your daughter who doesn't have
her own then yeah you can see what you
have checked cuz you're checking it out
on her behalf essentially followup
followups how um frequently do library
cards in your system expire I know
nashaa it's like five years um we just
changed it to two years every two years
they expire in that we want to touch
base with people and see if they still
live in the same place and have the same
contact information okay so every 2
years a person has to basically renew
their library card and verify the
information yes okay that includes
children's library cards yep all the
cards expire um after a certain period
of time or a period of disuse um the
system is sort of built in such a way
that they automatically expire and then
if any further activity with that
library card tries to take place it's
it's blocked it says hey your card's
expired see the librarian um and and
people will call us and say say hey I
still live in the same place can you
turn my library card back on and we do
so listening to this here's a
hypothetical suppose a parent wants to
know what books the child checks out so
the parent does not sponsor the child to
get a card but the parent at some risk
to loss by scatterbrain children gives
the child the parents card and the child
checks out the books no harm no foul the
parent knows what books have been
checked out because the kid doesn't does
have a card is that possible oh that's
yeah that's entirely possible thank you
yeah any other
questions
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman um so the benefits
to and correct me if I'm wrong uh the
benefits to checking out a book under
the parent would be that if the book got
lost that then it could get
replaced um I know I've done that
actually at the Manchester Library um
where it where my my son was maybe three
at the time and he kind of tore apart
the book and so I just bought a
replacement from Amazon and just gave it
a new book to the library with the same
title um because it was better because
it's like I I'm never going to be able
to return this so how would I just get
you a new one um so but the but the con
basically is that eventually the child
will have their own freedom of thought
and would want so I
guess I
do I I'm trying to form this as a
question um at what age can a child
check books out on their own and open
their own library card we have decided
at our library and of course this varies
from library to library that at 8 years
of age you can open up your own library
card if you're able to provide all of
the relevant information that you need
to open a library card so how would the
an eight-year-old pay their fee we
actually don't have fines in Lebanon um
but if an 8-year-old child on their
library card say had taken out a copy of
Harry Potter and lost it and never
returned it it wouldn't be the in my
library it wouldn't be the
responsibility of the parent parents to
pay for that that would be on the
child's library card if the child had
made the decision to open up an
individual library card and let me tell
you most of the kids especially if
they're nine or 10 and they want their
own library card they always want to
give me their mom's email address when I
tell them hey there's going to be emails
going out before your books are due to
remind you that your books are due to
remind you to bring them back uh do you
have an email address or do you want us
to phone you and they're like oh no why
don't I give you my mom's email address
we got to pick up the pace here any
further
questions uh seeing none thank you so
much you know that previous homage you
gave to your library that should be
recorded and put on public access that
was brilliant that was really good and
the chair next Rec recognizes Chris
urel and again the
4minute timer
rule
thank you ter Pearson members of the
committee my name is Chris archel I'm an
attorney with glbtq legal Advocates and
Defenders better known as glad uh we're
based in Boston but I'm a New Hampshire
licensed
attorney I'm here to testify in
opposition to HB
1308 uh I do want to point out that
there's been some discussion about the
scope of the records that um would be uh
covered under this under this bill uh in
the new section 2 a uh you know it says
all Library records related to materials
or services and the prior paragraph
there's a really expansive definition of
what records are actually protected by
the law um paragraph 2A could be amended
to say just material Just Books the the
names of books that have been checked
out right it could just be books that
are out for circulation but it hasn't
been narrowed in that way instead it's a
really expansive definition of records
and I'm concerned that it could include
things like internet browser history um
at a library uh
computer which of course is an issue
that's uh you know ripe for uh
discussion about where individual
privacy rights lie um the
confidentiality statute that's you know
proposes to be amended here it's it's a
statutory right to confidentiality but
it's rooted in constitutional
protections uh you know first amendment
uh protections and to to the right to
receive information right and and um
it's an essential right that's been
embedded in the Constitution forever of
course or as long as the Constitution
has been around same with the State
Constitution and um that that
confidentiality is is so crucial and and
I want to note that the American Library
Association uh uh which is you know a
major Library Association they interpret
the right to confidentiality to be for
children for minors to be co-extensive
with that of adults meaning they don't
see a difference between the right to
confidentiality for children and the
right to confidentiality for adults and
I believe the prime sponsor was saying
that every organization agrees with her
that privacy should be limited when it
comes to Children the American Library
Association does not
agree um in the school context there are
certain laws and obligations that
require disclosure of information by
schools to parents uh whe even when it's
not requested and that includes
information about treny and attendance
right information about grades uh there
are requirements for disclosure of
information when a student is the
subject of an investigation when the
student is uh alleged to be the victim
of sexual assaults these are all cases
in which statutes have defined um areas
where parental notification of
information is required and to date uh
there has been no law that requires
disclosure of Library information about
what happens at libraries uh in in um in
in in public schools and so uh I want to
talk for a moment just very quickly
about furpa which is the student record
disclosure law and you got one minute
yes that law uh requires disclosure of
certain certain records but it's
narrowly defined as records that are
kept in a central database um the
Supreme Court's interpreted Vera to that
to that extent um so the reason that I'm
here and I'm testifying in the first
place is just because lgbtq students
have a really special interest in
confidentiality when they're in a school
library I've heard from many lgbtq young
people about how the school library or a
public library is a place of sanctuary
for them a place where they can see
their life reflected can understand
really difficult things about their
identity and can get the strength and
skills that they need to go back home
and have these important conversations
this bill could put libraries and uh and
public schools in the middle of these
deep intense family moments that really
should be between parents and their
children and as was noted earlier in
this hearing there is absolutely no
reason that parents um should not have
unfettered access to their children to
ask them questions about what they're
breeding and uh and and this bill is
unnecessary to allow that free exchange
of information
between their
children I'd be happy to take questions
thank
you seeing none thank
you next nany is it
Beerman I think that's is it do we have
you yes we have
you eight years in the
house no relation to the Plymouth
restaurant
unfortunately sorry can't get you a deal
on a okay four minutes starting now
thank you um as I've listened to the uh
testimony that has been given
here I keep hearing that libraries have
to be responsible for certain things no
they don't if there is a domestic abuse
or a domestic issue in a home it is the
parents responsibility to inform the
school and the library wherever their
child is if there is a custody situation
that is not the library's job that is
the parents job and parents need to step
up and take responsibility for their
children I've looked into the library
policies of this town I live in and it
says it's the parents duty to monitor
what the child takes out from the public
library so if it's the parents duty to
monitor then it should be the parents
ability to also look and see what that
child has taken out um I don't think
that the library should be becoming be
coming between a parent and a child and
keeping secrets um we have seen more and
more times where schools are getting
between parents rights and children's
information and keeping secrets about
the child so if a parent wants access to
that information they should have access
that is their child nobody should be
standing in between them and a
parent and that's about it any other
questions concerns problems any
questions wow next time you come I owe
you two minutes and 44 seconds right I
have that over at the education
committee because they were only given
two minutes
yesterday no no it doesn't transfer they
have 107 bills I know so thank you for
your testimony and very much uh do
question yes question waving no yes go
okay thank you so much chair recognizes
let's see if I can get this last name
right Jil
B that's thank you grew up in a miltown
in
Massachusetts yeah you you to the
Canadian
hey I had an argument with a witness
before who insisted on calling himself
corer and I called him corn and I stuck
to
it well thank you Miss B thank you uh Mr
Mr chairman jel Binet I'm the legal
director at the eclu of New Hampshire I
have submitted written testimony it's
it's joint testimony between the ACLU
and glad which previously spoke and I do
promise to keep this under uh four
minutes we are in opposition to this
bill and I just want to Echo some of the
concerns that um that glad conveyed
about just the nature and scope um of of
this of this bill it doesn't just
include right the the checking out of
books But it includes you know Library
records related to use of Library
materials or services so it could it it
it really is everything so I just wanted
to flag that particular scope in the
event that um that is of concern to some
because it is certainly concern to to
myself um I can also say too that this
is I think much it is more at least in
my view than a disclosure law it it also
is a retention law from my vantage point
that all records need to be available
which means that I I think a plausible
interpretation of that is all those
records need to be retained and if that
is true then this is uh would require a
massive use of resources among our
libraries in this state some of which
may not collect all of the information
that's required to be collected under
the bill given how broad the the scope
is so I just want to flag that because
we all know it's not just libraries but
law enforcement fire are all strapped
for resources and I think this would
cause our libraries to be further
strapped for resources because the I
think this is a retention bill in
addition to a disclosure bill I do think
the privacy concerns here are are are
very real and I do think that this is
you know different than report cards and
that types of things like we're talk
when we're talking about books that we
read right in many circumstances we're
talking about uh we're revealing a part
of ourselves right and sometimes we
don't want that part to be shared with
the world and what we read can really be
an indicia of of intimate details of our
life whether we're trying to read a book
to Grapple with an abuse that we suffer
whether we're trying to read a book uh
you know because we're 17 and you know
we're trying to figure ourselves out
those are very intimate things and I
think we all know that we were all kids
once right and I think there are there
can be very real consequences to having
that information disclosed and outed
when that that child is not necessarily
ready could be safety concerns could be
other concerns but there I do think is
some degree of privacy here that is
necessary and that is what our statute
currently recognizes and I would submit
that it should remain in place I do
think there are more narrowly tailored
ways to address some of this and I heard
it earlier today which is get a family
library card if you're a parent that is
one way for parents to kind of monitor
but this is far broader than uh than
that and with that I'll I'll close my
testimony thank you one thing M
avocat that's Mr Advocate yes sir I I
don't speak a lick of French but I I got
that so I'll I'll speak in English for
you be so um there was a situation and
recently that caught my peripheral
vision where a kid really was I mean he
it was horrid what he did and people
said
well didn't the parents
Monitor and they really didn't so he was
downloading stuff and maybe checking out
stuff and all kinds of Horrid stuff
and gave him enough to know what to
do for Mash casualties yeah so
understood but your concern about a
child who's not ready to talk to parents
it goes across the ideological spectrum
and it concerns me in both directions
but you know when the question is well
who was monitor ing what this child was
inputting that speaks to this a bit uh
sure I think the concern I have though
is I think this bill goes far broader
than that and there are more narrowly
tailored ways to address those concerns
than to just completely eliminate
privacy altogether which is what I think
this bill does so for example there's
filtering software available right
within School libraries I'm sure people
behind me who are more equipped with
libraries can talk about that and I want
to get back to what I think is a more
narrowly taad approach as well if you're
a parent you know you want the ability
to monitor your child's his uh uh
history with respect to checking books
out you have a family library card but
this I think goes far beyond that which
is the concern that we have at the end
of the day thank you thank you
representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman uh so just briefly BR um
scanning the handout that you gave out
I'm under the impression and please
correct me if I'm wrong that case law
supports the current statute as it
stands about
confidentiality I I think that that is
our position um what I would like to
just flag again is the notion of
intimate details of one's life which is
the last section of um uh of our of Our
Testimony right because that's what
we're really dealing with here and which
makes this so unique in other words if
if we if we passed this bill then it
would be an opposition of current case
law um I think think because of the case
law there could be legal concerns raised
yes for all of the all the right to
privacy reasons they articulated sure
thank
you representative
Panic thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to ask this question and thank you
for allowing me to thank you
representative okay um this might seem a
little shocking what I'm going to say
but in the libraries
um it's our duty as a parent to oversee
what our minor children are being
exposed to and I think the concern that
parents are
having um and why this bill is being
introduced is that um they're afraid
that the children are being exposed to
um grooming Miners and normalizing
sexual behavior and for now um it's
culturally ad considered adults only so
there's supposed to be a certain
maturity level to be able to access that
information and I think with this bill
is trying to do
is protect the innocent children until
they're mature enough to make that
decision without stripping away the
parents
rights am I correct well I do have some
comments to it um I I think you know
again we're we're trying to balance two
competing principles here right which is
parental rights but all the notion too
that I I think that minors especially
teenagers have some privacy rights right
with respect to the intimate details of
their life including situations where
the government may be collecting that
information so I recognize the tension
right that's why we're all kind of here
wrestling with these these questions I
think the the concern that I have is I
think there are more narrowly tailored
ways to address it rather than wholesale
stripping privacy including the family
library card which puts that in the
hands of parents
right but I do think as well with
respect to obscene materials we have a
harmful to minor statute right I would
encourage folks to look at it um it's
RSA
571b um that that creates a process in
place with respect to uh
constitutionally unprotected material
going in the hands of minor so I
understand the concerns um I just think
we have other laws in place to protect
against it and my concern here is that
this bill is just too broad with respect
to what it's intended to accomplish
other question
seeing none thank you so much and this
concludes the hearing there being no
more pink cards on House Bill 1308 we
will come back at about quarter one so
uh Bona
Petit Mr
chairman are we meeting you here 115
there's an overflow room for those who
want to
overflow
I call to order a hearing on
cacr 25 and just for those who are here
um here's how we're going to do it this
afternoon I will open the hearing on
cacr 25 I just did and asked the prime
sponsor representative Hall to speak to
it and then about after he has spoken to
it and we have asked him any questions I
will put that into recess I will then
open cacr 17 and ask the prime sponsor
representative cordelli to speak to
that then from that point on the
hearings will be conducted
simultaneously because of the similarity
of the subject matter if you wish to
testify fill out a pink card you may
testify once today not twice even though
there are two bills you will if you wish
testify in favor or against one of the
bills or against the or for against the
other
bill or you may speak broadly to the
subject pro and con the clerks will be
keeping track of the pink card so that
no one will be called on twice
and with that thank you cacr representa
25 representative H would you speak
please to your uh Bill sure good
afternoon members of Children and Family
Law representative hle speaking on in
favor of cacr 25 I have just passed out
an amendment I will explain that during
my
testimony um I believe there was also a
copy of a memorandum from that someone
has requested probably the chairman
relative to Amendments of this style
over the last two decades thank you
chairman um W I mean I'm only as good as
my research staff who is very good thank
you research staff so I I believe
there's actually um several others that
um we can add to the list that is is
mentioned in that
memorandum um let me pull up my notes uh
um 2018 CAC R14 2017 cacr 2 2016 CAC R16
2024 and 2 uh sorry 2010 cacr
29 um 2012 cacr 31 2013 cacr
3 the list goes on I'm not saying that
it's
[Music]
not that we have failed a number of
times we have put this amendment forward
because we believe as a society that the
predominant role of parents is to take
care of their children that should be
the first thing that we look to not the
state not some other
organization I'm on probably three or
four of those amendments that I I
mentioned just now the bottom line is
who is the first person to take care of
a minor child the bill has introduced
puts in a conditional
phrase and we had discussions amongst a
number of outside
groups and there were concerns that the
conditional phrase could create
unintended
consequences at their request I updated
the draft to be something that has been
filed multiple times before and has
received positive recommendations um
from outside organizations and has gone
to the floor which is the verbatim to
cacr 9 of of 2011 and it occurs a couple
other times I think it was also verbatim
in 2013 parents have the natural right
to control the health education and
Welfare of their
children it's a simple Amendment do we
believe that parents should be the First
Responders in raising children or should
we look
elsewhere
um a number of times the state is has
gotten involved with
families and there's been serious
unintended consequences of that
involvement this would remedy that this
would give the the the parent who have
been had their lives intruded into a
chance to say look you're violating my
constitutional
rights there's a reason this bill in
some form has come up basically every
year since at least 2008 we may have
missed one or two legislative Cycles but
in one form or another in either the
house or the Senate it has come up it is
that important to the families in this
state so I would ask that you take the
amendment that I have handed out today
and offer that as during your exec
session on this
bill um I do recommend that only either
cacr 17 or cacr 25 go forward I am not
I'm not wetted to either one in terms of
who sponsored it I do think this
language is right in this amendment that
I have before you is actually a cleaner
constitutional amendment to lay a
foundation for the role of parents
within our society than the ones that
are in either 17 or the cacr 25 as I
filed it representative I think I know
why you would rather have one or the
other but not both but could you
articulate that for those of us who
aren't sure sure so it would
be it would be weird to have both on the
ballot if it made it that far in the
process I don't think that would do
justice the citizens might accept both
of them and they might be somewhat
confli slight there might be slight
conflicts in nature I think the better
process and I I I love I don't care who
sponsors it at the end of the day I
would like to see the language change so
if one gets with retained in committee
or in from studied and the other one
goes forward that's fine with me I'm not
married to the sponsorship I'm married
to one to my wife
but I would like to see the language of
the amendment go forward because I
believe this amendment has been vetted
the most times um in terms of actually
coming before the house um I can provide
to your researcher the list of other
times that this exact language has come
up I believe this is either the fifth or
the sixth version of this so there's a
lot of history relative to any
unintended consequences have been vetted
in the Committees it's been on the floor
but passing the necessary three fists on
the floor in a divided house is
sometimes
difficult um with that I'll close my
testimony unless there's any
questions
representative Gibbons thank you uh Mr
chairman uh what kind of unintended
consequences might you expect from this
bill so the question it's worded oh well
Bill as it's worded or the
amendment I'd rather speak to the
amendment than the original Bill the
amendment okay so the original Bill had
this if then therefore type clause and
you can create legal loopholes and I
don't want to necessarily go there
various legal groups looked at it and
said that could be problematic this year
I don't see any major unintended
consequences if parents forfeit their
rights by their actions in terms of
taking care of their children or
neglecting to take care of their
children or abusing their children
they've done some Criminal act that is
then puts them in forfeiture that's no
different than our constitutional
amendments relative to let's say the
Second Amendment the second amendment
guarantees rights regarding Firearms but
if someone's committed an act that
Society is deemed
unacceptable that that
constitutional provision doesn't apply
anymore because the the person has done
something that we as a society have
deemed unacceptable I would say criminal
acts against children clearly fall in
that section and even though there
there's a constitutional amendment that
would allow this to go forward someone
could still prosecute a parent for
abusing their
child just a
clarification although we do have this
amendment in front of us you cannot
speak to it directly because it is not
beneficially presented uh you can speak
to the broad philosophies and and
thoughts and so on making a an illusion
allusion to where you're going okay yes
representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question there's been a lot of talk
about parental rights these last few
years so of course like many I've done a
little bit of research and I was
surprised to see that uh at least
14 United States Supreme Court rulings
affirming the constitutional right
uh of parents to direct uh the
upbringing the education and the care of
their child um so I'm
wondering if this would add anything to
existing parental rights which again
I've I've I've I've seen at least 14
Supreme Court cases going all the way
back to 1920 which again and again and
again affirms parental rights AB
absolutely I do think it would add
something the Supreme Court has ruled
that parents do have the rights
especially when it comes to education
it's clear um maybe not quite as clear
when it comes to General Welfare or
health but definitely when it comes to
um education Pierce I think it was an
early 1900s
case um in particular I think this sets
the bar that parents are the first
accountable party to taking care of
their children if they're doing
right and there's an if in there right
then they should be allowed to continue
what they're doing if they are making
choices that create harm to the child
children that's a different story but
we're not talking about that we're
setting the the the foundation for the
proper role of of within a
family so I think it does add to the
Supreme Court especially when it comes
to health decisions because nowadays is
it acceptable for instance to choose to
to delay a vaccination schedule
one could think that the state's going
to get involved and say no you have to
follow the the vaccination schedule
exactly well it is there's enough doubt
in some of those vaccinations that
parents especially in the autism
spectrum of right are a little bit
concerned so delaying it might actually
be a good thing for the best in terms of
the best interest of the
child representative
Bickford thank you Mr
chairman would it be helpful if um one
of us introduced the amendment now or
was just the wrong
time it has to be during executive
okay
um it' be helpful but we can't do
it good
point um I I I guess my my question to
you is along the same lines can you you
mentioned fact ations there's any other
things you can think of that uh we would
want to go forward with this I think
examples would be very
helpful so there's enough doubt in the
medical community today what is the
appropriate course of action relative to
various
treatments
um that looking to parents to be the
first right parents and their doctors to
be the first person to talk to and be
responsible as opposed to the state and
the
doctors is a good
thing um I could imagine for instance
where some some medical provider says
that's that's a bad thing to and kicks
off a dcyf incident I I've sat before
this committee at least once on a
medication that was provided worldwide
multiple billions of times and has less
harm than
Ibuprofen yet that was enough to
trigger um a dcyf investigation so I
think there's real value in looking to
parents to guide and and own the
responsibility for education for medical
choices as well as for um the overall
welfare of the child children now when
they become right hit the age of
majority that's a different thing and we
as a society have chosen that 18 is the
age where that happens but up until
18 the responsible thing to do would be
to look to the parents does that answer
your
question well the followup thank you Mr
chairman um what you said so far is in
consultation with a medical doctor but
it doesn't say that
here in the bill or either so when we're
dealing with ccrs we're not dealing
necessarily with the level of exactness
that you would write a statute these are
guiding principles for how we as a state
want to have our society
often times this would be in the Bill of
Rights these are there these sections of
part first are there to restrain
government to not step over certain
lines so our constitution is structured
part first is kind of the bill of right
section this talks about the rights that
the citizens have prior to the
government being established and section
two talks about how government manages
itself this would be in section one as a
Bill of Rights and it would be the
foundation for legislation in the future
about well is it appropriate when you're
talking about the welfare of a child
that the parent and the doctor concur on
the treatment that's a legislation
statutory level discussion all right
thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you representative welcome and with that
I put
cacr uh 25 into recet
and I now open the hearing on cacr 17
and ask the prime sponsor representative
cordelli to speak to it it is similar in
some ways and different in some ways
and a handout is coming
around I'll wait for a second until the
handout gets passed
around
good to
go thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable committee members uh it's a
pleasure to be before this committee um
usually across the hall
um uh for the record my name is Glenn
cordelli I represent Tuftonboro wolfboro
and oopy in the beautiful Lakes Region
and um I bring forward um another
Constitutional Amendment related to
parents rights um it's a simple three-
sentence Constitutional Amendment what
passed around is the statutory Supreme
Court
references from multiple cases from
which I drew language for this
Constitutional
Amendment
um starting with the first sentence
about parents having the fundamental
right and responsibility for the
upbringing of their children um I cite
uh six five or six different Supreme
Court decisions with much the same
language as I have um in my uh
proposal um one in particular I wanted
to bring your attention to is number
three Pierce Versus Society of
sisters um it was an Oregon uh situation
where they had passed a law that all
children had to go to public school
schools uh the Society of sisters and
several private schools um filed suit
and it went to the Supreme
Court um in that decision by the Supreme
Court the child is not a mere creature
of the state those who nurture him and
direct his Destiny have the right
coupled with the high duty to recognize
and prepare him for future
obligations um you'll see in the other
uh situation excuse me the other uh
language from other supreme courtes
Supreme Court cases um very similar
language to what I have
proposed the second
sentence relates
to government
infringement um you hear heard some
conversation about that U moments ago so
specifically I address that in this
Constitutional
Amendment that in order to for the
government to infringe on parental
rights there has to be a compelling
interest and it has to be of the highest
order for the government to get involved
and that um is referenced in four excuse
me three different Supreme Court cases
um notable Supreme Court cases are
Washington versus glurg and Troxel
versus Granville um as recently as 2000
uh um the first reference you'll see is
to a uh Constitutional Amendment uh that
was proposed in the 113th Congress that
uh did not make it all the way uh
through the process but I thought that
the language in that um proposal was um
very applicable to the Supreme Court
decisions and what I wanted to include
in my
proposal and the third
sentence um was developed from the that
uh Constitutional Amendment proposed
before the 113th Congress as well as
working with a local lawyer and it is
intended to say that um this
Constitutional Amendment shall not apply
to any parental action that would abuse
or harm the child to answer questions
that were previously asked so I tried to
cover a number of bases um with this
simple three sentence Constitutional
Amendment and um uh I did a lot of
research into constitutional cases um um
related to parental rights and um have
um made them available for your um
review and I would also just add that um
I did run this by um a uh well-known
um legal firm the alliance for defending
Freedom um and uh they have worked on a
number of um parental rights cases and
um their review said and I quote the
amendment language looks very strong to
us um so that is my proposal and uh I
welcome any
questions representative
Petrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question and I do appreciate the fact
that you had submitted some excerpts
from various Supreme Court cases so
similar to what I previously asked is
there anything uh in this Constitutional
Amendment proposed that would do
anything more than what the United
States Supreme Court has affirmed again
and again and again that parental rights
in fact do exist Does this add anything
to what is our in uh case law the excuse
me um I I think that I tried to combine
sections from multiple Supreme Court
cases into one simple um paragraph for
our constitution as you can see by the
dates in these these issues keep coming
up even all the way up to the Supreme
Court um so I wanted to try and put as
much into a simple Amendment here for
our constitution um to avoid any um
future um uh issues that might relate uh
or cause a case from New Hampshire uh
related to paranal rights making it back
up to the Supreme Court again quick
followup
followup thank you so would it be
appropriate to have the good people who
are here to testify and to listen into
what's transpiring that
they do in fact have parental rights
would it be important to acknowledge
that to the many who think that they
don't have rights and that this
constitutional amendment is going to
give them something which they already
have I think that would be appropriate
to let the public know that yes you do
have parental rights and all we're
trying to do here is simply just
reaffirm it in our state constitution
but guess what folks you already have
parental
rights um I I don't see any problem with
that and um uh if you look at the end of
the bill there is a guide that would go
on the um on the ballot and I I think I
tried to make that clear um in that um
uh in that guide that would go on the
ballot do you think
that bringing various things that we
already have together in a one three
sentence concise statement would be
helpful my background to that is I've
been in hearings where the proposed Bill
really didn't add anything but it
brought it into neat Focus would your
bill be doing that um I would I would
hope it would be doing that um I think
it is important uh I'm from the
education committee and we have a um a
law book like this of RSA statutes that
relate to
education and we I cannot tell you how
many times we miss things when we write
new legislation because um things are in
different rsas throughout the Myriad of
uh education law um and we have to go
back and um correct things that we've
missed um
did that once or twice this year myself
for things I had missed last year so um
hopefully this will
focus um attention in article two of our
constitution um and cover three
important points I think that relate to
parents and their
children other questions yes
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman I have um two questions by my
right you may thank you uh and thank you
so much for being here um so all my
questions are regarding um language in
the bill so the first question I have is
regarding uh line three um your bill
says to direct the upbringing Education
and Care um and the prior bill that
we're kind of hearing together says to
control and I wanted uh to
know in your opinion what is
the the difference legally between those
two
terms um I I think that possibly uh
control um might
have um other implications rather than
directing um control
could
um I I don't want to criticize um
another bill but I think control um
could have uh ramifications in terms of
um
uh if the
child um has concerns they a minor child
but 14 years old and has concerns about
their upbringing and the
control of the the parents in their
upbringing is this bestowing rights on
the child in relation to the upbringing
of the parent okay thank you and my
second one is on um line number seven
and eight it says it shall not be
construed to apply to parental action or
decision that would end life or
otherwise physically harm a child um and
I personally appreciate you throwing
that in there um but under our child
abuse statute um being physically
injured is one part of our child abuse
statute but being psychologically
injured or or trafficked is the other
half of our child abuse statute and so
I'm curious as to whether or not um that
part if if if this Constitutional
Amendment were to be adopted would it
override our current prohibition on
psychological abuse or trafficking of
your own child I I I would not read it
that way no because neither of those
causes physical harm or death right but
um uh there are other things that could
happen to a child that I think would um
you would look to our statutes um in
terms of I I wouldn't see putting in a
constitutional amendment anything about
um trafficking your own child but
certainly um law enforcement agencies
would look to our
statutes uh to see um to see that as as
a penalty or or a criminal act um but I
wouldn't see that anything like that
being put into our constitution would
you I I think that I'm sorry would you
agree representative that the line one
the word inserting means you're adding
something it is not a replacement
language which could put what the
representative fears into Jeopardy this
is merely inserting additional language
therefore the existing language stands
would you agree uh I would agree the I
think all current statutes um would
stand um in relation to um parents and
their children thank you representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for coming my pleasure and U are the
are the Bills
structured so that it would need to be a
crime in order for the state to step in
to a
family um so in other words someone be
needs to be prosecuted and convicted
before they can disturb the family you
know that's wrong word uh intercede
maybe like a like um Department of Child
and Youth services or uh
DCF
uh
based I'm sorry I think the language
based on Supreme Court
decisions uh is intended just to um
indicate that the state needs to have a
com as the as is stated a compelling
interest and it has to be of the highest
order in order to step in um uh I heard
when I came in previous testimony about
uhu you know vaccines or you know drugs
and so forth um I think for the state or
any subdivision political subdivision to
get involved um it has to be of
Paramount interest of the government uh
to protect the child to
intercede okay okay thank
you representative
sidel thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um my question
comes from representative petrigno
actually forgive me if I once
misunderstood um we have other bills
that are coming up before us down the
line that have to do with enshrining or
codifying Bill laws that we already have
in place is that what the aim of this
bill is is to enshrine or codify what we
already have in place in regular stat
statute
um uh to a degree um uh we've tried to
um add uh to our rsas about parental
rights to put things all in one place um
without success um I think maybe a
better alternative um is the
Constitution um with a simple um few
sentences
to uh explain parental rights with at a
at a high level with the all current
statutes and future statutes still being
applicable to the parental um um child
raising
process thank you very much
representative the chair calls upon
ewin
Osborne somebody named
Osborne okay is there any are there any
and if you would mind not mind staring
around for a little bit please uh I have
no other pink
cards and what I have
suggested is unusual but not improper
and that is to ask both of you to come
up to the table the sponsors of both of
the bills and have almost like a
Roundtable it's not quite an executive
session it's whatever we're doing and
find a name for it because you know your
gracious comments representative at the
beginning um say to me that both of you
are really trying to achieve much the
same thing there may be a few
differences maybe some of of them are
linguistic but if we can get both of you
here at once talking to each other as
well as to us we may do my favorite
thing in the house which is square a
circle so with that representative hold
you bat lead off
sure so by no means am I an expert on
our constitution but I do read the
document fairly often at least weekly
relative to producing a pink sheet um I
want to point out words matter and I
want to bring up the New Hampshire
Constitution in Article 2 to talk about
that so which is not I'm going to use
I'm going to explain why I'm bringing
that up which is the first article in
this section of 2 A2B right is natural
rights all men have certain natural
essential and inherent rights among
which are the enjoying and defending of
life and Liberty arguing possession and
protecting property and in a word
seeking and obtaining happiness that was
what was passed when they adopted the
constitution in 74 they added the
following sentence equality of rights
under the law shall not be denied or
Abridged by this state on the account of
race Creed color sex or national origin
that sounds
great the technical issue with adding
that sentence the way it was constructed
is it does
allow
um to um to have a bias because of age
age didn't make this magic list it would
have been better if that Amendment just
said equality the rights under this law
shall not be denied or Abridged by this
state period but by adding a magic list
of things that are
contained what they did was said this is
the magic categories where you can
abridge rights but anything else is
still in play when we write
Constitutional Amendments we really want
broad language and not very specifics
we're not writing statutes different
it's a completely different construction
method I don't think anybody would want
to say our state authorizes right bias
based on age that would be
bad but that's what the Constitution
would allow the way it is constructed
legally in this I think the broader
language of the proposed amendment to 25
that I can't speak about is probably the
broadest one I do like some of the
sections of
17 um I think this is natural rights
versus fundamental that's the section of
the statute we're putting in it could be
natural fundamental it could be both
right there are good Court reasons why
youd use fun
fundamental relative to the Supreme
Court but New Hampshire right we call
them natural rights if we're going to
keep within our constitutional framework
I would use the word natural I don't
think it makes a big difference someone
pointed out the difference between
direct and control um that I would look
to a legal scholar to find out the
actual difference of those um we have a
constitutional amendment in this year to
change the word cherished to the word
cherish yeah um literally that's all the
one of the other constitutional
amendments does does is update the
definition doesn't change the language
in the Constitution at all it's because
words evolve over time because that word
matters I would ask that this committee
put a lot of time into the word direct
versus control fundamental versus
natural um that's my take I I have about
10 more minutes I have a bill
introduction um in another committee at
2 o'clock that's running a little bit
late but may I ask you representative um
I was going to ask this in a minute but
uh would it would it be possible for you
and would it be possible for you
representative cordelli to come up with
one
unified absolutely
Amendment would you like to try
it this is a late bill so we have a
little bit of
time um take the best of both Stand
United it Mr chair yes is it worth
having a quick subcommittee that we work
with to craft that language or would
like us to come
together cuz one meeting of a sub
there's time right and I don't need
another day at the State House nor does
anybody else on this committee given the
amount of time that we have here um
volunteering but maybe a subcommittee to
finalize the language so that
everybody's happy because we can craft
something but ultimately you need the
committee members themselves to also
weigh in if they have concerns and I'd
love to hear their concerns would you be
amendable to that representative a
subcommittee including the two of us the
two of you and three or four of us yes
okay who would be interested in doing
that anybody who's related by blood or
marriage to a judge
[Laughter]
oh or
not okay so representative sidal is
interested and representative
Panic uh anyone
else anyone else wasz raising your she
had her hand representative
who she's waving hi um anybody down the
row here M Mr um yeah waiting for me for
Zing bills okay we'll keep you posted
thank you both thank you very much both
thank you chairman um Okay so we've got
cordelli and Hull and sidel and panic
and uh repr yeah I'll feel one you uh uh
you want to be on
this no I want to get a another Democrat
in
there uh if I can yeah another Democrat
no no no well I want to be on it too
just I don't have enough to do Mr
chairman may I inquire make an inquiry
of you an
inquiry what all right call I I feel
very uncomfortable going forward with
Bill um without some real legal
consultation from somebody that's very
familiar with constitutional law I would
think the subcommittee would bring those
people in I know well that's why I put
myself on this I I didn't know if Chuck
Douglas is is that who's who's the house
attorney now I could take care of this
yeah we'll get we'll get a couple of
coners on without that I would not go
forward myself appreciate appreciate
that and I think we're going to have
that last time anybody
um all right well I hate to imbalance it
one way or the other but I am confident
that representative sidel and panic and
I can try to represent everybody uh as
best we can I mean we've done this
before here because I trust all you guys
okay with that in mind uh this is
absolutely extraordinary I close the
hearing on uh 17 I reopen the hearing on
25 and I close the hearing on
25 thank you all and we will do this
we'll visit this again in about a month
to six weeks thank
you